so first off I wouldn't stream anything
to YouTube so on your channel here
you've got some videos it's great I
wouldn't do it as streamed I would just
upload it as a regular video because
streamed videos get a lot less long-term
views on content but you speaking to the
camera is is great but it's not as good
as you coaching if you're a coach it's a
great looking video and you're talking
about what's stopping you from growth
awesome but that doesn't mean that
you're a great coach the fact that you
can just speak the camera it doesn't
mean that you're a great coach okay so
if you want to sell coaching I need to
see you coaching you'll end up
gravitating to and pulling in the better
clients to then actually go hire you for
coaching as long as it's still within
like what you want to do like if you say
yeah I can help somebody navigate being
fired from their first job and now
moving on to figure out their second job
or having a midlife crisis instead of
buying the Ferrari hire coach Mary
should help you out instead right is it
better return on investment there when
you have the the YouTube of Guru looking
at your YouTube channel you are in big
trouble
so I have the my experience
and I have the product but I am
completely lost in how to Market what is
the thing that you're selling
I am a reset coach getting people to
reinvent their lives using a five-step
process okay so what's the content that
you're making right now are you making
coaching content
if I'm making this is the Instagram yes
that's mine there she is all right coach
my mom I'm following perfect okay so
where are
so you're doing IG lives here and then
are you bringing people up or this is
what are you doing here no I just post
the reels and posts I do a stream yet
lives and okay YouTube videos
uh okay so you're doing it so you have
people join you on stream yard and then
you post that to YouTube after yes got
it okay and then the link here is to
your YouTube channel so let's go check
that out to get some here we go
why are you laughing
when you have the the YouTube guru
Channel you are in big trouble no this
is good it's all love it's all love
Barry come on it's all love okay so this
is this is this is it right I'm looking
at the right one yes that's it okay and
then these are
these are the coaching sessions you're
doing
no I I have done private coaching
sessions but they are not on YouTube
yeah with my friends and family
and then I I I have been able to to help
them with my
strategy of SWOT analysis to find their
strengths their weaknesses their their
opportunities and then the threats
but I can't take them further on how to
monetize the talents that they have
rediscovered
okay so so marketing now we need to see
you coaching
okay
we need content of you coaching so first
off I wouldn't stream anything to
YouTube so and on your channel here
you've got some videos it's great I
wouldn't do it as streamed I would just
upload it as a regular video because
streamed videos get a lot less long-term
views on content but
you speaking to the camera is is great
but it's not as good as you coaching if
you're a coach
okay like the fact that you can make a
post what was your Instagram
uh talking about like what's stopping
you from growth by the way I love look
at the where are you this is crazy where
are you standing right here it sounds
beautiful
country in in Calgary that's beautiful
wow thank you I love it so but like
that's a great it's a great looking
video and you're talking about what's
stopping you from growth awesome but
that doesn't mean that you're a great
coach
the fact that you can just speak the
camera doesn't mean that you're a great
coach
okay so if you want to sell coaching I
need to see you coaching okay that comes
now to the Second Challenge I have I set
out to like I thought I thought that my
Niche was people who have burned out
like people above 50 my age great
who have been out and who think they are
a failure who are failed and they are
struggling not knowing where to have to
continue and I thought I set out to help
them reinvent themselves but now I got a
few weeks ago when I got more than 200
subscribers on YouTube
to take the the analytics very seriously
so I went to the audience analysis
analysis and I realized in the
audience disagree disaggregated data on
gender and age that most of the people
who are watching my videos 64 percent of
them are men
and
not 67 percent of them are men and 64
percent are between 18 and 24.
and another the other 30 30 how many
percent are between 25 and 34 and 34. so
there's nobody above 50 or where maybe
they don't have enough data to to give
me and so I became completely lost
I don't know now should I continue doing
the videos the way I'm doing them or
should I change to some Snappy way of
doing things the consumers are more
younger people so I got lost and that's
why I started doing live streaming
because I didn't know how to do videos
that would suit that age group should I
continue the way I'm doing the videos or
I should focus on those age groups well
you're saying you don't know how to make
videos to hit the age group but you're
already hitting the age group in your
analytics that the the bigger question
about that is who do you watch you want
to serve so
does I mean you started the business and
you thought you'd be helping people who
are 50 plus who are struggling with kind
of the next step in their life uh
now you're helping you're actually
helping people on your content who are
much younger
does it matter to you if you if you're
doing resetting for people does it
matter to you
their age
it does not I mean I was just mind blown
by because I focused on something else
and then I got a different result but
you know as a communicator I'm a I'm a
journalist so as a communicator you know
the generations the way you communicate
to them is different
so I don't know now maybe I have to do
some Snappy videos to to come down to
the generation or I keep the way I'm
doing I don't
um that's where I got challenged
so you're a reset coach and and like
your IG bio says you help reinvent
yourself but you help people reinvent
themselves with a five-step process to
rebuild self-confidence improve your
network so you help people reinvent
themselves
yeah this is what this is that's who you
love helping the most yep cool so where
you come in and help us anytime somebody
needs a reinvention which might be when
they're 50 and they're hitting their job
and trying to move the next step it
could also be
as they're trying to figure out what
their first job should be or their
second job or their first marriage or
their second marriage or whatever right
I mean you take athletes who are done at
35 and they can't compete anymore what
do they go off and do next they have to
reinvent themselves right so
it's less about an age demo and more
about the life stage that somebody's at
when they need a reinvention
okay
so uh I don't even worry necessarily
about having
um snappier content or finding which age
group to go to I'd focus more on doing
coaching sessions with people who need
to reinvent themselves and let the right
people come find you
so if you're doing your coaching
sessions it's with people who are like
you've got 233 followers right now on
Instagram let's go you know first the
first 233 is the hardest 233. so in
there who is looking to reinvent
themselves right now and then that
becomes the coaching content that you do
okay
so it's regular whether you if you want
to use stream yard cool you can
Instagram allows you to hack other
people's audiences as well so you could
go in live with somebody on Instagram
Their audience gets to see that you're
live with them too uh they might
um promote it as a collaborator as well
but it's seeing you coaching so that's
the best kind of content you can make it
doesn't mean that you stop doing like I
love it you're outside in Calgary
beautiful mountains you got a great
message for growth it's awesome uh cool
thank you that doesn't mean you have to
stop those but that content won't lead
you to generate as as many clients
if you're selling coaching if you wanted
to be a speaker
then maybe
but if you want to be a coach and you
want to sell coaching because you
already are a coach and if you want to
be a coach but like what are you selling
if you want to sell coaching I need to
see you coaching
okay so if I was doing Instagram
breakdowns if that was my business right
cool I we just did a quick little
example okay okay Mary like look here's
your Instagram and here's we gotta
here's what we have to switch up then
somebody else would come in and I could
help coach them on Instagram and then I
could sell my Instagram coaching
Services right uh it's not what I want
to do but that would be the model so
same thing for you you're getting people
who need a reset in their life
and creating content with them
and coaching them through the process
coaching through the five uh not the
five hours the five what's this
five-step reset process reset that's
what it was not five hours you put them
through your five-step process
and then I get to see oh Mary's awesome
maybe she can help me too
and for anybody who's looking for a
reset in their life
maybe they call you now but it's not
depending on age or gender or country or
whatever else
if that's not actually important to you
like if you don't care if they're men or
women or from Canada or United States or
Italy or you know wherever no I don't
care I just want to serve right but who
but serving people who need a reset yep
so that's what you're all about so it's
not about the demo like how you Niche
down is not based off of the demo or
like age group it's based off of or
gender it's based off of do they need a
reset right now in their life
okay because when I saw that I thought
maybe I I missed my like my calling was
to use my experience to help people who
have gone through divorce and I so I
didn't want to say divorced women
because that will continue the stigma
the word divorce so I I so now I don't
know if I've missed my mission
oh
I just continue with
resetting their lives their finances
they are I don't know
well you you have it you haven't missed
anything you just continue to reset
right so you know in your own language
like here's the thing like do you want
to help
yes women who are divorced and that's
where you want to be the expert at or do
you want to help anybody who needs to
have a reset in their life
I think everybody I wanted to help women
in particular because I thought that
those are the people who have a big
issue on trying to find themselves when
they when they fail at something
but well maybe that was just some
subjective analysis
I don't know
well a lot of guys are lost too
a lot of guys are lost too kind of scary
a lot of guys are lost too but here's
what here's what will happen if you
actually do
if you actually do coaching sessions
like if you if you start messaging your
233 followers and you start dming them
and say hey if you need a reset right
now I'm happy to do a free coaching
session with you
we'll put it live on Instagram
what you'll end up finding is
uh different people will be attracted to
you but they still have their own
version of what they need a reset of and
you may end up niching down
it's based off of still like matching
what your heart wants to do with what
had kind of practically makes sense but
the niche may be completely different
like maybe why are all these 24 year
olds uh needing resets or it's like 18
to 24 well they're trying to figure out
going to college or not do I go to
college is it still a good thing to do
they're in their first job do I do I
stay in this job or not I thought I
wanted to be an engineer but now I
realize that I hate it and I want to be
something else right they're trying to
figure out do I stay in this
relationship you know do I marry my high
school sweetheart or do I go and do
something completely different so but
people are having resets all over the
place throughout their lives
as you start actually doing the coaching
you'll find the best people that you
love working with the most
okay so it's in the doing like if you
did a hundred coaching sessions with
people
all around and not not being judged not
not that you are judgmental but not
saying it has to be women 50 plus
divorced
and you just said you need a reset I'm
going to help you navigate that
okay you you have it open to more people
and you'll you'll end up gravitating to
and pulling in the better clients to
then actually go hire you for coaching
as long as it's still within like what
you want to do like if you say yeah I
can help somebody navigate
being fired from their first job and now
moving on to figure out their second job
or having a midlife crisis instead of
buying the Ferrari hire coach Mary
should help you out instead right is it
better return on investment there here
if I pull up my most recent book right
momentum
on the back
I I said what you can use she's got
there you go you got your coffee too
like on the back like use this book to
launch your business write your book
begin a healthy habit create your
Masterpiece kick off your podcast start
your YouTube channel game momentum and
the goals that matter to you the most
because these are the most common things
that I get asked to help people with
so it'll be similar with you like hey
work with Coach Mary to to help you
reset your life to like what if you've
gone through divorce figuring out your
first career you know swapping to your
next job trying to get into college or
not like whatever the main things are
because ultimately I don't care if I'm
helping somebody launch their first book
or start a YouTube channel I just care
about people getting their message out
to the world
absolutely it makes a lot of sense that
becomes like how do I create how do you
create a Regular Show at least once a
week like the the the starting point is
once a week the ambition point is daily
so somewhere in there like where do we
want to play but at least once a week of
about you coaching people and anybody
who needs a reset and that's who you
then bring on look at movement makers I
don't care what country you're from what
what what uh your background is Men
Women age like we've got somebody asking
yesterday how what's the diversity like
in movement makers it's like it's all
over the place like
lots of men lots of women absolutely all
sorts of age groups like so but what's
what's common is everybody wants
everybody's got a message and they want
to get out to the world
and so that's the thing that binds
everybody together so for you like it
doesn't matter where they come from but
everybody needs everybody comes to you
is looking for a reset to make that next
shift in their life
okay that makes a lot of sense thank you
so now talking about publishing a book I
have a two complete manuscripts of my in
my computer I don't know how to go about
them publishing them so I am challenged
by the copyright issues or how to get
the books out to the public so what's
the copyright issue
I had a a Blog that somebody downloaded
and published a book and published it in
a book and had the audacity to send it
to me to edit it for the person
and so I really got blocked and I I
really don't don't know so now I have I
have as a as a communicator I have I
write and write and write I do Knowledge
Management and stuff
but I write the things and they stay
there I don't know now how to I really
don't have that
push
to bring them out
well you have to decide if you're going
to go self-publish or try to work with a
publisher
if it's self-published you can get them
up on Amazon today you you could I mean
you gotta you gotta get a design for the
cover but it could be basic like you
don't need the beautiful thing about
Amazon is you can keep updating it so
you can launch it and you can change the
cover if you don't like it you can you
can change the manuscript like you can
keep updating it if you want but if it's
just to get a book you could
self-publish it and you can have it
ready to go you get an ebook that you
sell from your own website like you can
you can have it up if you want if you if
you want to get it published and you you
go with the publisher you start
submitting it you could talk to Kira
who's my business partner in in Freedom
House about getting the book out to the
world
um
so those are your two options right
there's pros and cons to both
but you could like if you just wanted to
get it up you could the the challenge
with the book is you still need to
Market it
okay because having a book on Amazon
doesn't mean that it's anybody's gonna
buy it
so I because now I I have a very tiny
budget for that so I would go
tilt more towards self-publishing and
so you're saying if I'm going to do
self-publishing it's easier but I have
more work to do
yeah exactly it's it's it's
maybe not easier it's like it's easier
to get up I guess
you know but it's it's harder for you in
terms of it's going to take more time to
to create and post and figure out how to
do it yourself or or work with someone
even a movie makers like Terry Wade
Thompson could probably be a resource to
help you he's done a whole bunch of
different books other people have
self-published their books too but
Terry's gone through the process a lot
so you might have some tips to get you
there faster the the challenge with it
though becomes
the book without marketing is not going
to generate more business for you
okay
so I would love to see you start making
more money
and then you can afford to hire whoever
you need to to do whatever else you need
to
right so people tend to default to more
like okay oh I need to write a blog or I
need to write a book or I need to like
just create more but
creating more doesn't mean that you're
going to get more clients and get paid
more so
if you're a coach having a book does it
add some credibility uh maybe you know
like these days it doesn't really matter
that much if you have a book or not if
it's with the publisher maybe it's in a
bookstore maybe but are you still buying
books and bookstores you know I don't
know it's like it's not what it used to
be the reason I write a book is because
you want to birth it into the world you
get a big message and for my books like
this just this is better in a book than
it is in a series of videos
but
I didn't need this book to like
immediately generate business for me
if I was you I would focus on how do I
grow my coaching business you might have
big Ambitions and huge things you want
to do and maybe start your own
publishing company I don't know you got
lots of things that you want to work on
uh but what's the fastest path to start
making some money inside of your big
mission
and if you're self-coaching the fastest
math is coaching so what's going to help
you generate coaching clients
your two Best Bets are coaching content
so like a book isn't coaching content a
book is you being a thought leader again
right so coaching content ideally videos
where you're showing right
um and any potential Partnerships like
who are they
uh who are people going to when they
need a reset so for example you
mentioned divorce cool go talk to the
top 50 divorce attorneys in Calgary
and say here's what I do
right so that somebody's going through
the divorce maybe they recommend coach
Mary
like hey if you're struggling with this
you should talk to coach Mary
that makes sense no I was talking about
the books because I already have the
manuscripts completed so it's as well as
finding a way to get it out and instead
of keeping it in my computer
it doesn't save anybody there
sure yeah a hundred percent but and like
you're not serving anybody if if we're
not generating Revenue too absolutely
right so like if you build the coaching
business up and then you have 10 coaches
underneath you and now you've got a team
you can serve a whole lot more people
whether it's through short Snappy
content or books or speaking tours or
whatever else that you want to do right
so usually you know the immediate
priority you can tell me you can tell me
no it's like hey you know what I don't
need to make money for the next three
years I'm good so tell me what to do
next okay but usually like monetize
becomes important and what's the fastest
way is through coaching content and
through referral Partnerships so like
divorce attorneys is a good one
um thinking about other people whether
it could be accountants it could be
lawyers like other lawyers other
accountants like someone who's just sold
their like when I sold my business I
could have used you when I was 22. I
sold my business
I made money great but I didn't know
what to do next in my life
like the thing that I just dedicated
myself to was gone
it's a good problem to have but it's
still a problem like okay what do I do
next and I just explored a bunch of
different things but
um maybe talking to you could have
helped right if my lawyer said hey talk
to coach Mary she might be able to help
you
so who are the people who can give you
referrals
because they're dealing with these
people all day long and a divorce
attorney
is not guiding people through how to
reset their life they're just they're
just guiding people through how to not
get screwed in the divorce right like
it's not their expertise yeah so
uh and it doesn't just have to be
Calgary I say power because that's where
you are and it's it's it's close but you
could make Partnerships with divorce
attorneys across North America
like get so much business from
from your marketing strategy that then
you can do whatever you want with books
and speaking and employees and whatever
else you want to go off and create
so like the book exists on your lot on
your computer awesome but there's still
a there's still a Time cost to get it
like if you're going to figure out the
sub-publishing route there's still a
Time cost to figure all that out and get
it up
okay thank you so much and before you go
do I need a business license to do to go
into entrepreneurship in Canada so
there's a couple types of businesses in
Canada you've got your you know sole
proprietorship
uh which just means that you're running
it off your name or you can set up a
corporation
the the pros and cons
um the main issue is around liability
How likely are you to be sued so if you
go Corporation you can set up your
corporation the easy you know you need
to get a lawyer to help you it's not
expensive but there's annual filing fees
so you'll probably spending at least two
thousand dollars a year just to maintain
your corporation
so not the end of the world but if
you're not making money two thousand
dollars a year is still two thousand
dollars a year so the starting point is
you just do sole proprietorship and it's
based off of your name
the only
um downside is if you get sued
then they come after you personally
okay so now you gotta ask and you know
I'm not giving legal advice here over
Instagram but
find out if I need it then I'll go get a
lawyer yeah well so it's like if you
think you're going to be sued you think
about the types of advice you're giving
you know coaching is a it's a low
likelihood scenario right like I leave I
I run a dance studio right like the
largest dance school in Canada for salsa
dancing
um we have I don't know a million
dollars liability insurance like if
somebody comes in we've we've never had
anybody sue us
um but if somebody slips on the floor
and breaks their leg or something like
we've never had that but if that
happened right that's why we have
insurance but that if I didn't have a
corporation
if Trinidad salsa was not a corporation
then they could come after and Sue Evan
Carmichael okay right so uh if I'm just
giving YouTube strategies or something
they're probably not gonna like the
likelihood of somebody suing me is a lot
lower
so for some Industries it's very high
you know for salsa dancing or anything
physical anything anything health
related if you wanna people Sue like
crazy there so you want to make sure
your your uh it's a corporation for sure
and you have insurance but uh at the
beginning in a coaching business
uh the likelihood's pretty low but it's
one of those things like as soon as you
start making money from it it's good to
turn it into a corporation
um if you ever want to have business
partners too you need to have a
corporation I don't know if you ever
plan on giving up Equity or shares in
your company but uh then you need to
have a corporation to make that happen
okay thank you so much yeah
all right Mary well grateful thank you
so much so next step is we got to start
booking like action items to Do's book
the show book guests are you free to
coach and make a list of 50 divorce
attorneys in Calgary to go start
connecting with and see if you can build
a relationship
that's how we started to build this
business
thank you very much
amazing Mary we love you have a great
week
yeah we'll see you Movie Makers next
week thank you very much
I was not expecting this so I'm caught a
little bit off guard well I wasn't
either but here we are yes
so let me ask you something so I I went
to the person that says I'm I'm infj too
which I think is how we first connected
or you're coming to know something I did
or I commented something you did and I
forget way back
um
so Thursday so today's Thursday Thursday
is my extrovert day even though I'm
super introverted Thursday is where I
just put on my extrovert hat and all day
long I'm doing interviews and podcasts
and hangouts and IG lives and I just
find it easier and I don't know enough
about infj but maybe this maybe this is
actually really helpful or maybe just
I'm super weird but
I like having I like knowing that just
one day a week
I get to do all my interviews and just
cure the energy I should gain more
energy over the day by being just in
that mode and I don't have to worry
about
writing writing my next book or or
making videos or anything else
um
is that do you find that that is uh like
one are you the same way in that you
like having different things with
different days uh and two is that is
that like an infj thing or is that just
hypocracial is a weird deck
people to put ourselves out there and to
connect with other people so scheduling
it all in one day definitely helps a lot
and I need to be a lot more intentional
with that for sure
um I usually do a lot of it on Thursday
too because I have a couple of things in
the evening that I already have
scheduled so I'm like all right let's
just get it out of the way
um and plus it takes us so much time to
recharge that it's like why not do it
all at once and then have the whole rest
of the week to recover from it and I
also like knowing what's coming right so
I can be prepared for it I like that
routine too
so someone so so Maxie Mac Max CC wrote
that you're tired after your extrovert
day here's the thing so for me
the it's it's just kicking it off that's
the only thing that really
is the this is the hard part right so
um I just finished doing uh I have a
YouTube course and I just finished going
live in that group and leading up to
that I'm I'm nervous and worried and
like who's gonna show up and what
questions are going to ask but after the
end like that was amazing
right and so then I see Sarah go live
like I want to join in let's go live
together Sarah right like it it I
actually gained more energy so so by the
end of the day I'm probably gonna crash
but but come like two o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock whoever I'm talking
to uh I'm actually bringing the whole
energy up that I'm bringing Sarah's
energy all the way forward to the end of
the day but it's just getting started
that I find really difficult so that's
why I have one full day for it because
if I did bits of it every day then I'd
have the challenge of getting started
every day as opposed to just starting
once a week and then I have that whole
day to carry the energy forward yeah I
used to have this same thing in fact I
used to tell people that I hate people
like I don't like being around people
because it's just so draining and it's
so much but once I started my podcast
and I started doing a lot of interviews
earlier this year with
INFJs and other people who are intuitive
and it was the same thing when I was
getting ready to do an interview I'm
like oh what am I doing I don't want to
do this this is really hard and I would
have to force myself to actually do it
but during the conversation I could feel
my energy level rising and by the end of
the conversation I'm the same with you
of like yes that was so awesome let's go
do another one because it was so cool
it's it's the connection that we're
looking for and connecting on things
that we're passionate about and talking
to people who care about what we're
talking about just that deep those deep
conversations that we really want it's
not that we hate people it's that we
hate shallow conversations yeah we want
something that's deep and meaningful
yeah in my language it'd be like serve
right you built the serve you want to
know that the work you're doing matters
and is serving other people
um yeah a thousand percent like if you
woke up and felt like the work that you
did matters
I think that's such a great gift and
you're you're willing to you love you
love actually talking to people knowing
that you're helping them we want to help
others so we're afraid of others and
their judgments and you know opinions
and everything and so like that's the
constant battle
um yeah I'm with you I was on an
airplane uh late last year I was
speaking at an event in Puerto Rico and
I was on an airplane and I hate talking
to the guy next to an airplane
right like hate it I never do it
um I remember everything about this guy
that he woke up at you know two in the
morning to catch a flight to get here
and he he likes his coffee decaf with
one sugar and one cream and all this
stuff but he's trying to make small talk
and it's like
I'm just trying to not be rude right
it's like yeah let me just let me do my
thing I hate talking about the weather
or the cushiony airplane or like
whatever
um but then I when I landed in Puerto
Rico uh I found out that he was at the
same event that I was speaking at
he was and then and then uh I saw him
the next day and then we started talking
about
his business and how I can help him then
it was an instant click because if you
know that that you can help them you can
serve them it shifts the whole
conversation because now there's a lot
of depth and meaning much more than just
hey so why are you going to Puerto Rico
and just kind of make small talk yeah
yeah so can I ask you I haven't done a
lot of Live Events but that's like the
next thing that I want to do in fact I
was
scheduling some right before we got
quarantined which was terrible timing
but it's terrifying for me to talk in
front of people especially in person and
I'm hoping it's going to be a
significant amount of people right at
least you know a few to begin with I
used to have a job where I had to speak
in front of like 25 people but it was
kind of a rehearsed thing so I knew what
to say every single week yeah how do you
deal with that I'm assuming it's a lot
more draining than just being live on
video so how do you deal with that uh so
I don't know that I call it draining
it's definitely a lot more stressful
um and again maybe you're the eye and
you know you're you're the infj like
master so I'm I just can speak from my
experience but
uh last year I was in um Arizona
speaking of defense and Dean um
bradskioski and Brandon burchard put on
this event every year did a couple
thousand people it was you know Eric
Thomas and them and and me I was like
Eric Thomas tonight were the only
external speakers kind of brought in to
speak a couple thousand people and
10 minutes before going on stage is a
super lonely time like if you're in a
backstage at a big event nobody talks to
the speaker before they're about to go
on because they don't want you know it's
just like leave them in their zone so
um
I I decided I was gonna go off with no
slides just because right so now I've
got to speak for an hour with no slides
so there's nothing even to save me it's
like oh right yeah I'm talking about
that thing right
and um I I forgot what I was gonna start
with
so I I was backstage kind of pacing
practicing just trying to remember what
I was going to do and I I forgot how I
was going to open up my speech
and I just had this now mental image in
my head of me going up and bombing and
failing and and disappointing everybody
and it's all my fault and holy cow this
sucks
um and I haven't had an anxiety attack
like that in a long time to that degree
I'm always worried about disappointing
people but not to where it's like
crippling and I forget and and it's
still service that saved me so I I
peeked out of the curtain and I looked
at the audience and I said I'm not I'm
here for them like I'm not here for me
this isn't even about me
I have information that can help those
people that that Brendan doesn't know
when Dean doesn't know and Eric Thomas
doesn't know I have I have knowledge
that can help those people stop being
selfish and get out there and and help
them and that calmed me down
maybe that maybe for others it just adds
more pressure but for me it's like oh
it's it's about serving people and I
have knowledge that can help that is the
thing that um
calm me down maybe remember what I was
going to do when I got on stage and then
and then went off and they ended up
giving me extra time on stage because it
was going so well which is great
um my favorite part of those things
though isn't even the stage work it's
the afterwards and this seems so weird
for an infj or maybe it's normal I don't
know
um I stay in the hallway for five or six
hours after the event like for me the
the joy isn't the speech it's the
one-on-ones afterwards
and I'll stay until the whole thing is
done I'll go home back to my hotel and
like die afterwards but I but I'm so in
the zone of helping people that I'll
forget to eat and forget to go to the
bathroom and not notice that I'm running
a fever because I'm I'm just in the zone
of helping people so much and I love the
speaking not for the speaking I love the
speaking as the setup to have people
come and ask me questions after so I can
help them
um
yeah so
that's what I do
I love helping people too and my biggest
fear as well is disappointing people
every time I think about my podcast or
the courses that I'm doing or you know
just being on Instagram it's like okay I
don't want to disappoint anybody and
every time I get terrified I go back to
that too I'm here to help people and if
I can just help one person then that's
all that matters that's why I started my
Instagram account I thought if I could
just help one person and I never
expected there to be 50 000 people on my
Instagram account ever
we're just starting
what's happening I did because I just
started it like a year and a half ago so
yeah I'm I'm definitely a lot newer at
this than you are you've been doing this
for a long time
YouTube yes Instagram I'm a little bit
newer I went hardcore on Instagram maybe
two years ago
um YouTube 11 years I've had my my main
channel for so uh yeah it's pretty it's
pretty wildly crazy so here's the thing
though like if you're afraid of
disappointing people but you also want
to serve that's where most people get
held back
because serving involves other people
you can't serve without helping other
people but if you're afraid of
disappointing them then it's like having
your foot in on the gas and the break at
the same time like you know you're
capable of more you know you want to do
this thing but you're so afraid that you
don't go anywhere and you're just
spinning your wheels and so
um that reminded to myself at least is
like this is this is service this is to
help somebody my attention is good they
may not get it it may not work I may you
know you may start a podcast and it
sucks and you may go live and make a
mistake but the intention is good as
long as the intention is positive the
intention to serve almost always that's
what ends up happening yeah so I want to
ask you a really big question because I
know you probably don't have a lot of
time
so many people ask me how do you find
your purpose so I'm going to ask you
that how do you find your purpose so
your purpose comes from your pain right
it's why well this is why I wrote built
to serve right I mean because I got
asked that question so many times and
it's not that difficult
um it doesn't require years of
meditation or journaling or anything
else you just think about what is the
most painful moment for you as a human
and not like I broke my arm or something
not physical pain but emotional pain
when you felt the lows to the low you
felt worthless you felt like you have no
um no you know you're no point in life
um and you've grown from that you've
come out of that you're not
you're not where you want to be yet
because we're constantly growing but
you're way better than you used to be
whether that was six months ago or a
year ago five years ago
um there's lots of people who currently
are who you used to be
and your purpose is to go help them
and you represent help to them and
people default to thinking well I'm no
Tony Robbins or I'm no Brendan burchard
or whoever
soon they're going to say I'm no Sarah
[ __ ] but
you can help right like you can you can
help the person who you used to be if
you think back to that person who used
to be five years ago you can help that
person in a way that Evan Carmichael or
Tony Robbins whoever can't
and so there's it's just understanding
there's lots of people who currently are
like that
um serving others is hardwired into US
it makes you feel good we all know it
they've done they've done functional
MRIs in people's brains and found that
that serving others hits the same part
of the brain as having food and having
sex which is also which are also
important as humans uh and and so it's
like it's hardwired into you to serve
and to help
but there's a difference between just
serving like buying the coffee the
person behind you in line or holding a
door for somebody this is the moment
these acts of of service Good Deeds
versus a deep
fulfillment of helping other people go
through the thing that you went through
um so I love helping entrepreneurs
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
you know I quit on my first business
partner for a day I came back the next
day but I was like the lowest moment in
my life and so I want to make it easier
for other entrepreneurs not to struggle
and suffer as much as as I did I want to
make it easier for introverts to step up
like how does an introvert get on stage
and talk to 2000 people and have a
YouTube channel with 300 million views
and all that I don't know like I'm
figuring it out I mean I've done it and
I want to get even bigger
um and and just sharing that can be an
inspiration hopefully to other
introverts as well so that the pain that
you went through uh can either Define
you from a negative and you stay you
stay lost and trapped or can Define you
in a positive and say hey this is my
chance to serve and give back and help
everybody else is currently suffering
with this same thing
yes for sure but that's that's exactly
how I found my purpose too that's why I
started my channel is because I was lost
as far as what my personality type was
and learning about it and I thought hey
if this information can help somebody
else then
yeah I need to put it out there I need
to do that and I was one of those people
who thought I didn't want to help other
people I read that about our personality
and I was like that's not really me I'm
more of a stay in the you know behind
the scenes type of person but then once
I started helping people
then I really found a passion for it and
I realized that's what I want to do and
I want to do more of it and more of it
more of it and
pushing myself past all of those fears
and insecurities is difficult but then
you go back to your why and yeah that's
worth it
I love it look what's happened
girl we just got the lies it's great I
love it anyway I saw you go live and
like this is awesome I wanna I wanna hop
in and just spread some love and thank
you for the conversation and I'm so
pumped to see you continue to grow where
you've come from such a quick amount of
time and I'm so pumped to see where you
take it in the next year and a half
yeah thank you and thank you so much for
all the inspiration I love your book I'm
telling everybody about it
um yeah thanks for joining us I really
appreciate it amazing thank you Sarah
bye bye
the man what's up my God how you doing
man hey man came a long way from the
apartment man we're in a condo now man
look at that look at that everything we
moving up my brother I love it man I
love it but uh Evan I wanted to talk to
you man I got a question so okay I just
they just allowed me to monetize my
YouTube channel okay great I've been
over literally total 400 million views
within other motivational company
channels and what I'm having a problem
with right now I have over millions of
comments and like King hollers we love
you we love you I don't know how I'm
gonna like to be to get the millions of
people to come over to my house like the
Creator yes I'm talking about defeat
this Evan I'm popping out all this
content on William King Hollis the fan
base is growing but
they I'm trying to get them to know the
face not the voice like come come over
here I got so much new stuff like yeah
so here's what you do you take those
videos that that you are the voice of
and you take the same name like take the
title of that video and you make the
same video on your Channel
the title the title right so like I
don't know what I don't know what
channel you've been on that like you've
got whatever you're being like what's
the biggest video Fearless motivation
motiversity I work with Dana every
channel okay so Fearless motivation like
what's what's the name of that video and
feel this motivation
Fearless motivation uh mostly feeling
motivations video is like um
per contract we do contract deals
basically it's like you get what I'm
saying what's the name of the video on
Fearless motivation uh it's called um
one video is called uh the journey
great so that's what you call your video
on your Channel
okay make a new video you make a new
video called The Journey
on your tell a different story
you've got a million stories you could
tell about the journey right I mean
you're you're the content you could just
spit it out ASAP uh but you call it the
same thing the journey call it like
whatever all and if it says Fearless
motivation don't call it Fearless
motivation but the journey on your
channel William King Hollis like
whatever however you want to get like
what's what's the official name you is
like King in your official name or what
clean house
great so like King Hollis and then your
goal is anytime somebody watches
diffused motivation video you still want
that video to win I mean it's still
spreading your brand and it's getting
people to know you right for sure
but your goal is after that video is
playing for your video on your channel
called the journey to show up down the
side
okay right so we're taking people from
their Channel finding us and and you do
that for every every big motivation
channel that you've been on you make the
exact same title different video don't
don't I mean
you just gave me work for the rest of
the day there you go create my own
version in my own style of each video
The Journey recreate it I got you that's
yeah but but like different story right
I don't want to piss off your list right
like you sold that one yeah perfect new
store and and you're full of them dude
your journey you're on a New Journey
every day my god listen I want to tell
everybody listen to this man I I was
questioning Evan the other day and um I
was questioning like am I pushing out
too much content I got over 386
unreleased speeches I'm talking about I
can't get them out fast enough but I was
telling myself is it ever possible to
over saturate the industry like
oversaturate
um the material you push out Evan and I
I know I heard you right
um on one of your I mean saying one of
your training videos you said push out
the content push out the content every
day I'll do a video a day no matter what
I do three videos a day no matter what
and I was like yo Evan like every other
echoes in my mind in my head say yo slow
down Wheels slow down but right now in
the time of the world in right now I
feel like
like it's basically I'm like a kid
Trapped in the Closet full of chocolate
chip cookies I've never had a chocolate
chip cookie I ate my first one now I'm
about to eat the rest of the entire
closet I'm that excited every day so I
got so much like so much material and I
wanna I'm asking basically ask you Evan
it's so it's too much too much
we do three I'm sorry we do six videos a
day across 12 channels
and I'm just I'm just like I'm just
starting dude I mean the thing here's
the thing we're not that important
if you think about who who people are
they're subscribed to you and you're
subscribed to me and Gary and Grant and
Les and and
Oprah and all these people who are all
pumping out content
you're like one out of 100 subscribers
that they have
right like that we're not that important
right there's gonna be some hardcore
there's like five people who like you're
the only Channel they subscribe to and
they're not gonna be pissed if you're
pumping up more more love right but um
you can't you can't like this it's not
possible to over saturate it's not
possible anymore this is too much
there's too much out there you're giving
me gold nuggets thank you so much E I
got one more I got one more question and
um I got one more tip for you too after
so so give me your question I got one
more bit of advice for you go I got a
serious question because I get this I
get it all the time Evan and you a
motivational Guru in my eyes
is it do you when you when you hear my
work and then you hear
um Aaron Thomas work not debating on who
the best none of that stuff but I'm
talking about do I sound similar to him
like is this is it a similarity to him
or is it do I have my own King Holland's
different type of tone I'm asking you
because I get that that question a lot
and I'm kind of getting to the point I
don't know if you ever experienced this
Evan but I'm getting to the point where
I really don't I really don't like it I
really want to be my own man and my own
brand but I want to I want to ask you
that question does it seem like um it is
like as if I'm biting or is it just my
different style or is a different style
I'm asking you from a professional level
I love E.T I've spoken the same stage as
him
um I think I think uh I wouldn't be
bothered by the comparison yeah I think
there's a there's an energy that you
both bring I think
um
there was a gap in the market in terms
of like there was there was less brown
and then there was nobody for a long
time and then et popped up and then and
then there's other guys who were also
now coming on the scene and and people
have a similar Style
yeah princeier princeier
I was hanging with him in Puerto Rico
like a couple weeks ago a month ago and
yeah he's pretty dope
oh dude and he's all his style is a
little different though in that he's
he's very uh like
he's more soft-spoken he's not energy in
your face uh
heart Centric thoughtful not that you're
not heart Centric and thoughtful but the
energy you bring is more you're gonna
show up like dude I tell people that in
the live before you join get ready for
some energy it's coming we got we got
the king coming in the house and so uh I
think from that I think from that
approaches it could be easy for people
to to confuse or to make the comparison
but just keep going man I mean I
wouldn't be offended by it
I use your entire model you thought
where I was I literally showed you where
I was living the first time you use your
entire model without ever being able to
meet you without ever being able to see
you that's why when I talk to you Evan I
always tell you bro you are one of the
most valuable Kings on this planet
because you don't you don't just talk
about your own motivation you talk to
help other people create their own lanes
and for individual to wake up every
single morning important to the world to
help them tap into their full potential
that that right there is that that's
that's god-like that's that's a that's
like an angel man and we I know a lot of
people on here and I say thank you bro
because my life is changing from the
moment you put my video you didn't even
have to put a video up of me and you did
and then I got I got so much attention
man I just got a from professional
athletes reaching out to making history
in Milan uh speaking in Kingston Jamaica
and in all these different places uh
they started with Evan basically showing
us the blueprint and I want that last
tip Evan before I go man before I get
off okay okay so I got two now I got two
now for you so one and if I look at E.T
I think about the whole when you want to
succeed as bad as you want to breathe
like that's kind of his thing that he's
known for uh I like yours I think yours
stands out even more which is King like
it's just so easy to remember
and I would go heavy on on King not and
and what's so great about how you do it
is it's not just you calling yourself
King you also call other people all
alone yeah
yeah I love it it's like it's uh
you're making people feel special you're
making people feel like they need to
they need to create something amazing
that they're worthy of being called a
king and so I would really leverage that
brand like I think even your hat like
forget the Nike hat give me the King hat
you're a king I'm a king right
I'm wearing my I'm representing dude I
got my gear on
no but like that's the thing like when
you're coming I'm learning this slowly
you told me to pick you said everybody
gotta have a word something that
represents them and yours was believed I
I always use King so now you basically
saying put them on hats and shirts will
oh yeah yeah yeah and have it in your
like have it in your videos you know
have it in your videos when you're
recording YouTube video when you're
joining somebody's IG live right you're
popping a mind you live for some people
it's the first time I've ever heard of
you like who is this guy he's the king
and so now they want to go and follow
you and see what start to mess with your
stuff
um if you're ever if you're I would even
try to incorporate King into your
speeches
like in your next Fearless motivation
talk about you being the king you're the
King right it's like you're you're known
as the King guy I want to be who doesn't
want to be a king right go check out
everybody my man everybody wants to
right so I think The Branding is how you
can start to stand out because if you
look at an ET I look at last ground it's
possible for decades it's possible like
that's all he talked about and and if
everything was around it's possible
right and ET succeed as bad as you want
to breathe is a mouthful but uh you know
I'll follow his stuff for so long that
it's easier for you to remember but King
is is even is even shorter it's like
it's one word four letters how can you
not remember that and Evan to be honest
with you
um you always talk about
um
um Evolution okay things and you do a
very good job of adapting to that and
what I'm starting to realize in the
motivational industry the listeners are
changing the youth the new generation of
um
people who listen to inspiration it's
like it's like um like now like I get
artists like you get the hip-hop artists
you get the rappers the mainstream
rappers that come to you and be like yo
man I've been listening to you every
morning late nights in the studio I'm
listening to you every morning so it was
really exciting me Evan is
being able to be a part of the evolution
of motivation you get what I'm saying
and I wonder if I'm asking this and
saying this to see if you see it just a
different type of listeners and
inspiration a different type of people
that that's that's dude it's a human
thing right it's a human thing and and I
think a lot like everybody needs
inspiration motivation and they need a
daily right uh
and I think a lot of people now would
have a heart like a lot of Youth will
have a hard time connecting to a Les
Brown now
yeah yeah I mean it's like I've talked
to less every other day and he's saying
and dudes dudes I think it's the
greatest speaker of all time young Les
Brown but I think now he's got his his
kind of Grandfather jovial you know live
to him he's a great dad now man and it's
great it's just I think somebody who's
uh 18 or 24 or whatever is going to have
a hard time connecting to that and so
they need a new voice and so I love that
you're standing up uh if I'm you I would
try to connect with all of the rapper
friends that you're working with and and
try to do a collab on their next album
for you to do spoken words E-40 artists
on BPZ I did one with him and I'm
thinking about doing the old DJ Drama
thing where I take all the hot songs of
now and create a positive inspirational
intro before this basically try to bring
the why out of the song I don't care if
it's negative I want to try to get to
the point where
um it's basically talking about okay
what's the reason why you do this you
talk about
what's the purpose behind it and um
that's honestly what I'm thinking about
doing Evan I want to start hosting
mixtapes man I like it I like it but I
think I think if you collab with people
and and even if there's somebody you
mess with this is somebody who's like
this up and coming rapper that you mess
with and you just love their Vibe and
you you reach out to them and you send
them a DM on Instagram to say hey man I
mess with you I like I like where you're
going uh I love to do a collab here's
what I do and you send them the most
fire thing that you've put together I
want to do a spoken word against like
let's do a song again let's do a rap
together I'll do spoken word you do you
do your thing and you're like the I
would love for you to be the pit bull on
all of these people's albums you know
like Jayla comes out that DMX file you
remember that that
yeah but that's like that's not
something et's doing right it's still ET
is going to turn 50 soon I mean he's
looking good he's still doing his thing
older man he's getting it but but like
be the pit bull who who who is who's the
spoken word guy in hip-hop
on out like nobody you can you could be
that guy you know who you know who
um the E-40 said I reminded him of was
DMX he said he said you remember what
DMX used to give the prayers
on his album he said will so so
um
that guy was so rough so hardcore man
but energy and passion no you felt it
yeah yeah yeah I do I know I know DMX is
I love I love I mean it's the the lyrics
may not be how you want it but the uh
the energy and the vibe his
um his ability to I learned like the
voice right yeah his voice was it was
liberating it will Rumble your soul Yeah
Yeah
by E40 telling me that when I went and
listened to him he said okay listen to
DMX and tell me how you feel and he said
that might be the same feeling that you
give off to a certain amount of fans and
it and and that in that fan base that
DMX had when they say man I wish DMX
will speak longer on these tracks now
I'm creating an album my album pain and
purpose did 300
000 streams in in two weeks so I'm it's
just it's basically like a new genre of
music and yeah and I'm basically I've
been looking for a way to evolve and you
basically taught me that what if I went
and got a rapper and said no I'm not
gonna feature on your track you got a
feature on my track I'm gonna do the
intro you're going to do a verse and I'm
going to do the outro and we got a full
song right there
yeah so I want you to think more
collaboration like you're doing your
work you're pumping out your content
you've got oodles and you've got 300
whatever awesome more stuff coming but
stop the next evolution is new Notch is
doing everything yourself
solo you've already kind of done it in
the in the motivation world with the
videos but now think music
yes it's great for you to do your own
mixtape but I want you I want you
collabing with other people on their
albums on their on their sets so that
you're the guy who for all the up and
coming rappers that are coming up it's
like who's this guy who's just Spitting
Fire even if you only have like eight
lines in the thing it's the thing that
people remember right and King is always
in a messenger okay I gotta go but one
last one last thought if you look at the
motivational videos that I've done
spoken word on on people's channels go
look at the comments section I've
responded to like every comment for the
first six months to a year of that video
being up so what I want you to do is go
and to all those channels and look at
those top videos every day if you're
trying to build your audience you look
at every new comment you sort by most
recent and you respond to every single
comment on that video and say thank you
for listening to my voice thank you for
for watching this video I I I'm glad you
liked my speech and so it's like you're
making that connection
because Fearless team Fearless they're
not responding to comments period and
then here's this guy the king who just
did a 800 comments responses Sandy thank
you so much for listening to my voice to
my speech I'm glad you like my content
they may not even have made the
connection before but my voice my speech
who is this guy they click through to
your YouTube channel and then boom
here's this new video right the Journey
part two coming from you love King all
right much love man cheers to see me
coach another entrepreneur one on one
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there sometimes I need
to really choose what are the dreams
that I want to pursue it's a constant
evaluation and you have to be willing to
let go of the good to go for the great
if the overwhelm is I don't know how I'm
gonna make this thing then default to
just immediate action